Url_for accepts the name of the function
as the first argument, and a number of
keyword arguments each corresponding
to the variable part of the URL rule.
So if my URL needs a variable for
a restaurant ID and
a menu item ID, my url_for statement
needs to look something like this,
taking in three arguments for
the function it will call and the
variables to pass into that function.
So back in my template I can add this
code inside my anchor tags right
after the href equals.
Since this is a method in Python and
I want the output printed on to
my HTML document, I will enclose
it with a double brackets.
When I save my code now,
I see that there are edit and
delete links for each menu item below.
So you may be wondering why you would
ever want to build URLs instead of
hard coding them into your templates.
Well, now if you ever need to change
a URL path, with URL building,
you can change your URLs all
in one place without having to
remember to change URLs all over
the place from within your application.